Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Sergei Young, who is the founder of the
Longevity Vision Fund and also author of the
new book, The Science and Technology of Growing
Young.
It's so great to have you on today.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, thanks for having me
today.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
So let's just jump right in.
I've recently been reading in addition to
your book, The Book Scale by Geoffrey West.
And one of the things that Geoffrey West talks
about is that when it comes to human aging,
when you look mathematically at metabolic
rate and a few other sort of basic factors,
it seems as though the top end kind of natural
lifespan, if you avoid car accidents and infectious
disease and you know, the best scenario is
about 120 years of age.
Now, one of the things I find really interesting
about your book is you start to talk about
this insteps.
You talk about living to 150, you talk about
that.
So you're not just jumping in and saying,
as some do, a thousand years of life span
is very, very soon on the horizon.
You're talking about incremental.
So talk to us about that.
I mean, how do we go from this natural limit
of 100 to 120?
Up to 150?
Speaker 3: Perfect.
Great question.
So.
Well, let's let's start from today.
What are the options that we have today to
extend our lifespan?
So, frankly speaking, all of them people call
them boring or.
My mom told me that.
So it's lifestyle changes.
It's early diagnostic use in power of wearables
technologies.
This will help us to live 200 healthy and
happy years.
So that's that's what we can do today from
today's like a stage of development of technology
and science.
This is actually pretty important because
we have something exciting in the field of
longevity, science and technology coming to
all of us in the next 10 to 20 years within
what I call in the near horizon of longevity,
innovation.
But it's very important to stay on longevity,
breach and be as healthy and happy as possible.
So then in 10, 20 years time, our body and
mind is worth extending its resource.
So that's one.
And it's like a separate part of the book
as a bonus chapter is is as much as twice
as long as any other chapter.
There's so many things you can do to cool
it down.
Longevity choices.
So then the second piece is a near horizon
of longevity, innovation.
And again, this is technologies and scientific
breakthroughs which will be valuable to all
of us in the next 10, 15, 20 years.
And when people ask me what are the most exciting
from this list, I'm always talk about gene
editing in gene therapy, organ regeneration,
our ability to regrow and replace organs inside
our body, similar to what we do with the old
car.
Extending its resource and longevity and appeal
in the next 10 years will have a completely
new class of drugs which will focus on aging
and score rather than any particular disease.
This is the kind of drugs that we have today.
So that's again near horizon of longevity.
And then there's something more on the horizon.
Its goal for off eyes of longevity, innovation.
And I'm talking about technologies which will
be available to us in the next 25 to 50 years
from now.
And this is when man and machine will become
one.
When we talk about integration between computer
power and human intellect and without changing
the definition of human, it's going to be
very difficult to live beyond Cunnington 20
or a hundred and fifty years.
Speaker 1: So, OK, let's let's stop there
for a second, because that's really important.
So you you seem to be acknowledging that there
is this sort of metabolic and cellular natural
ceiling to human longevity that is going to
need some more major change or intervention
in order to be extended significantly.
Speaker 3: Yes.
So what we can do within the current biological
view on the human body, biological perspective,
we the limit, whether it's Karnet or a hundred
and twenty or a hundred and thirty years,
I don't know.
But it's obviously in this field.
So then we need we would need to complement
the biological perspective and engineering
or technological perspective and look at the
integration of this for us to be able to live
longer.
But the bigger question is not the science
and not in technology.
The biggest question is ethics and regulation,
because we have created technology to extend
our lives, David, but we haven't created life
that we want to extend 60 to 80 percent of
people in the world, depending on the country,
would say no to life extension opportunities.
So we will need to sort out a lot of ethical
issues and almost create a new amazing version
of this world and society for us to embrace
the idea of longer living.
I call it morality of immortality.
And this is my biggest worry.
This is my biggest concern.
This is what we need to have a conversation
about ethical choices before we embrace the
technology.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, you know, I've interviewed
longevity researcher Aubrey de Gray several
times over the last 15 or so years, and he
often makes news for the things that are more
salacious that he says, like the first person
to live to a thousand has already been born
or something like that.
And, you know, maybe that's true, maybe it's
not.
But that what I find more interesting about
what he says are when I bring up the ethical
considerations, how triage considerations
change if the upper limit of life is extended
or what is the economic impact, what is the
environmental impact of people living so much
longer?
He says it sort of will mostly work itself
out, like if people live a lot longer, the
birth rate will go down, for example.
What do you think about that?
Speaker 3: So I do believe that there's so
many things that we need to change in this
world for us to be able to enjoy this far
horizon of longevity.
So few of them, like I do believe in longevity
and longevity.
Technology, has an opportunity to become a
unifying theme for the nation and for society
because someone need to close the inequality
gap, which is widening all the time.
So I didn't my mission is to bring affordable
and accessible version of digital health care
and technology to the world.
I'm not interested in to create something
for the rich ones.
Right.
So that's that's one second.
Is this whole relationship with Mother Nature,
as you pointed out, when you leave seventy
five years, there's always a temptation to
say, OK, I'm going to die in 20 years from
now.
Next generations will sort it out for themselves.
If you're going to leave CUNNINGTON Twenty
four hundred and fifty years, I do believe
that it give us an opportunity to be much
more responsible in our relationship with
what the planet or the Mother Nature.
We're going to face the consequences of our
own actions.
Or the other thing is and it's probably the
final comment on the ethical side is social
constructs.
You know, this binary social constructs that
we have today, like career, marriage, retirement,
they've been developed in a society where
the average lifespan was thirty five years,
like two thirds of the marriages are going
through divorce in the first five years of
their life.
And this is not great.
And we would need to come up with a variety
of the options for, you know, two people in
this world to be to fix their responsibility
for like kids growing or anything else or
this whole career thing, a retirement thing.
It's all so binary.
It's just you work full time and then you're
like full time retire.
And two most dangerous years of your life
is the year of your birth, because we still
have this high infant mortality and ear of
your retirement, because you lose in today's
binary framework, full time work, full time
retirement, people lose the opportunity for
social realization.
And this is one of the most important component
of you, your desire, willingness and ability
to live longer.
So we just need to rethink.
Can I have as many careers as decades in my
life?
I need to have an answer to this question.
And our society needs to be ready and and
change itself on its norm to accommodate this.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's a very interesting
social question about increased life spans
that I've read about, which is maybe both
from the standpoint of career and even for
some people from the standpoint of relationship,
there would be more more chapters where you
would plan on more chapters maybe than people
plan on.
Now, let me ask about a couple of other kind
of finer point things in the longevity circles.
There's a lot of talk about the possibility
of drugs, specific medications providing additional
life span.
Often the diabetes medication metformin is
mentioned.
What is the what is the real data on metformin
as a longevity drug?
Speaker 3: So the whole issue is that aging
is not cancer is disease today, so there is
no regulatory framework for someone to launch
metformin study, which would test a particular
outcome of taking metformin a regular basis
for your longevity.
And this is where we are today.
I do think that, you know, all of us will
have an opportunity to invest more time and
resources into improving our health and lifespan
when the regulatory change will will happen.
Having said that.
There are so many cases in medicine and the
history of medicine where something has been
discovered is a side effect and apparently
this is what happened with metformin.
So it's clear that for certain portion of
population, certain age and relation to diabetes,
metformin adds to three, four years to the
lifespan and health span.
Well, the question is whether it's works only
for people who are in a particular risk group,
like suffering from diabetes or it works for
the general population.
And this is still the question that we need
to resolve.
So that's why I'm on the board of American
Federation of Aging Research and we are working
on a trial.
It's a huge trial to be launched hopefully
next year in the US under FDA approval and
guidance, where three thousand people will
be taken metformin and we'll have more data
in three, five years from now.
Whether we have a new class of drugs, which
which is looking at and focusing on aging
and the score or metformin is a great diabetes
drug.
But unfortunately, it doesn't really have
any particular positive lifespan extension
impact on the other parts of population.
So it's very promising.
But as everything in medicine, we well, let's
just test this before we embrace the idea
of looking before reform.
So that's why, you know, everything I talk
about the nine year horizon of longevity five,
10, 15 years from now, I'm always saying,
guys, be conservative, unless you've been
advised by your doctor to take it and insist
you have a critical condition.
Well, it just wait.
Stay longevity.
You reach for five, 10 years.
And so then we can embrace, embrace and use
these technologies and this scientific discoveries
in much more responsible and less risky weight.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that seems eminently reasonable.
And if people Google metformin longevity,
they will find a lot of hyperbole that does
not yet match.
As you're pointing out, the data very important
life expectancy over the last few years is
actually down slightly in the United States.
And of course, we're in a pandemic that has
on average slightly reduced life expectancy.
We have big disparity based on economic situation
in the United States.
When you're looking longer term at longevity,
what do you make of this short term reduction
in life expectancy?
Speaker 3: So it's clearly a US problem.
We haven't seen any other developed nation
on this planet which would show this very
difficult.
Say it with a lot of love, right.
This tragic situation with life expectancy,
I mean, smaller numbers decrease of zero point
two years, right.
Every year.
And it's happened in a in the last three years
out of five pre pandemic.
So the reasons being is is something needs
to change in in the health care sector in
US.
US has the most expensive 18 percent of GDP
and the most inefficient health care system
in the world.
UK United Kingdom spends eight percent of
its GDP on health care and has much better
results, like Singapore spend five percent
of their GDP on health care and they're on
number one or number two place in the world
health spend wise and a life span wise together
with Japan.
So something needs to change and and obviously
this huge impact of opioid crisis to this
number.
So we will look at this problem.
It's going to be better.
But obviously there are a number of fundamental
problems, like with obesity, with a diet of
Americans, with, you know, high degree and
and intensity of antibiotics in the meat and
fish, etc..
So having said that, there is a light at the
end of the tunnel because in medicine of the
future, it's going to be much more technology
driven and based on data.
So that's why I'm raising a lot of wearables
which are coming to our life.
Wearables is not a convenience device for
you anymore.
And it doesn't matter whether it's feedback
loop or Apple Watch or Oring does not matter.
It's going to be our personalized health care
device and the change in health care will
come from new players doing completely new
things.
This is where I see the solution to the current
crisis in the medicine.
Well, two of the
Speaker 1: really two of the things you talk
about that I love because so many longevity
investors really don't talk about it.
Our number one, we have to make life such
that people want to extend it.
No.
One, that's very, very important.
I'm glad you mentioned that.
And then number two, there are economic questions
about access and you seem to be addressing
both in the book, which I think is great.
Speaker 3: Thank you, David.
Yeah, it's very important, like in the US,
you know, two zip codes next to each other,
15 years of difference in the life span.
I couldn't find even, you know, logical or
rational explanation behind that, you know,
a part of inequality gap that we have in this
world.
I mean, it's and the US is not an exception
like in London.
You know, this same situation will give you
in some of the cases, 17 one seven years difference.
Well, that's why I'm embracing technology.
We invest in technology to democratize access
to health care, like decreasing the cost of
cancer diagnostic by two, five, 10 times,
decreasing the cost of ultrasound diagnostic
by 10 times.
And this is real numbers from the startups
that we funded or decreasing the cost of organ
transplantation likely or transportation by
10 times.
So I'm very hopeful that this will give us
an opportunity for all of us to be as brave
as thinking of health care is a basic, good
and basic service which would need to be provided
to everyone for free of charge.
This is my dream.
Speaker 1: The book is The Science and Technology
of Growing Young, we've been speaking with
the book's author, Sergei Young.
Sergei, so great having you on.
I really appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you.
David, stay healthy and happy place.